I was watching another interview you did
and you said that graphic is a guy who
feels no love for anyone did I say that
yeah if he feels no love for anyone
maybe himself
might answer my question what do you
think drives him to fight to get what he
wants or is it just revenge and revenge
alone at this point I think it's
seeing the pain that he feels in the
eyes of
other people it's cruel I think it's
like it's foul like a feeling as he has
about himself and what he's been through
he needs Nick and Taylor to feel too uh
yeah and actually like I think the first
couple of episodes now I think about and
I've seen it and was definitely evident
in reading the script is it is about
wanting them to
experience the pain that he feels
they're partly responsible for at least
and that kind of carries through he's
not just trying to take over everything
he wants them to see him doing it they
have I have noticed that and it crumbles
my heart into a million pieces it makes
it darker right it's this is this is
easily one of the darkest Marvel shows
or movies I have ever seen and it's
largely because of what graphic I think
is all about at this point because as
soon as that spreads out
to you know just the cause or the who's
right I saw it's like it's really
personal and I think something much more
the scary thing about it too is seeing
it start so small and intimate via his
personal connections and knowing the
widespread ramifications if he could
take it to the next level freaks me out
um this might be pushing it a little but
again going back to the thing that he is
a guy who feels no love who do you think
the last person he loved was that's a
good question
whatever iterations early on where you
know he was a
there were scenes that maybe didn't make
the car or parts of the backstory where
he did have well yeah he had a he had a
family and
I guess maybe yeah at what point did it
shift
um
I think realistically speaking like it's
it has to have been a long time since he
has fought so maybe when he was a kid
maybe it was like before he got I don't
know uh but yeah I don't think he
arrived there last week yeah I think
it's been a while I love thinking about
backstory and Theory type stuff so he's
also someone who comes across as
extremely confident in himself and his
plan at the very beginning of the show
so at at that point when the show first
opens up do you think he thinks he has
any weakness is there anything about
himself that worries him that if it
comes out he will not be able to see
this point no I think he thinks the
ultimate weaknesses trust in other
people or believing that there is any
good in anyone so like
the only weakness he is
might have felt he had his dismissed
it's about it's no one dude this is like
the darkest headspace oh this is why I
was this was the kind of stuff I was
like well it has to be this right
otherwise it's not he's not a villain
and we like it it has to be he had to he
has to hold that 10 you have you have to
want Fury to finish him and so
you go like well these choices are maybe
better than okay I think so yeah I'm
gonna flip it around a little bit
because he is a villain he is a bad guy
doing bad things even in just the first
two episodes alone but he does seem like
the type of villain to me where his
intentions will you know not necessarily
be justified but at least make sure the
audience understands yeah you're gonna
understand by the end you'll know
exactly where he's coming from and how
he's got there and why he feels the way
he does but whether you think that's
right or wrong over to the person with
with that mentality does he have any I
don't know admirable ass it's like even
if they were ultimate
ultimate turn him into
that he is now is there anything along
the way that's been admirable about him
do you no no no I I'm shining in terms
of the show when we meet him so when
when this story
when this story starts
he's gone he's like he's he's all the
way down there and there's no bringing
him back and there's some great stuff
where Talos tries and that was really
interesting to play like how close can
we get to like seeing him coming back
and then he doesn't know him yeah like
or
perhaps he could like if you locked him
in a room for long enough okay I'll
spoke the rat maybe he could but in this
show I don't think
that's it wouldn't be easy do you think
he's able to uh see any divide between
right and wrong or is that line been
completely obliterated for him is there
no line he won't cross to get what he
wants I think he thinks
I think he thinks everyone is a fool for
thinking anything other than the way he
thinks
like I Loved Before
and I was such an idiot
now I understand the truth now I
understand the truth about how
uh messed up we all are human Scrolls
dogs cats kid with anyone are you the
type of actor who could turn it on and
off and leave all this behind the second
thing
once you've done all of the thinking
it's just making choices to be and I got
concerned for you the more that you
describe this uh this headspace here
what was dark was like like looking at
all of those cult leaders you know like
over the last 20 years and like looking
at their behavior and looking at like
what they were able to do and how
convincing they were able to be but
actually what was going on underneath
and that's some like crazy documentaries
out and you go no these these these
people are real and so yeah it was kind
of sort of like coming to the decision
to go like oh what would happen if
he really trusts no one not a little bit
not like kind of half a glimpse no one
what if like
like imaginatively if you really got
your kicks out of like that's why that's
what made it interesting for me make
some scary character to watch all of
this is also making me think I think
it's your very first scene in the show
it's when you're sitting at the table
drinking the cup of tea and your body
language there is just so incredibly
striking because you're just like
casually lean back and you're putting
like a million sugar cubes in your tea I
didn't know that was going to be the
first scene I think I think it was the
first time I remember it definitely is
the first scene but it's funny in the
MCU they shift things around sometimes
so it's like oh that's interesting that
was that wasn't originally what the
first the first thing was something else
that is here and there and so you go oh
that's like an interesting like edit
move you know I don't know if you
remember your goals in that moment with
much specificity at this point because I
know you shot a while ago but is there
anything in particular you wanted to
convey in terms of the way he is
carrying himself from an acting point of
view you have to look at like who who it
is that you're talking to so like who
and then what does that character like
represent to him how does he feel about
them so anyone working for him
is just an idiot they could be saying
anything to him like it's
it's uh I think we've we've uh uh pagan
I think graphic feels like he's the
worst kind because he
he's ambitious and he wants to be Derm
or Hamden but he doesn't have the guts
to take it so the level of hatred in
that moment towards Killian's characters
I didn't share with him was I guess was
the only point of concentration with me
I was like what like what would happen
if you like you really
test this guy but you kind of need him
around as well like you need him to so
it becomes really like fun in your mind
because you're like you just base
everything on like if you trust no one
hate everyone what level of hate do you
feel for this person right now in this
moment and then it's like yeah this is a
great part I love these I love this now
I need a whole back story about their
relationship too you just kind of make
it up as you go along but yeah